los rescatistas trabajaron durante toda
la noche buscando desesperadamente
señales de vida una explosión en una
mina de carbón en el norte de Turquía el
viernes por la noche mató a muchos y
dejó a decenas de Mineros atrapados bajo
tierra este hombre uno de los
Afortunados escapó con vida no podía ver
nada Todo estaba cubierto de polvo y
humo no sé qué pasó el humo y la
oscuridad ni siquiera se podía ver la
luz cuando estábamos allí solo sentíamos
la presión Todo estaba cubierto de polvo
no podíamos ver nada los amigos y
familiares de los mineros No tardaron en
congregarse en el lugar con la esperanza
de ver a sus seres queridos salir del
subsuelo los primeros informes indican
que fue una explosión de metano la que
provocó la tragedia
el sistema de ventilación de nuestras
Galerías funciona actualmente de forma
adecuada algunas zonas están
parcialmente colapsadas la primera
evaluación realizada por nuestros
equipos indica que la explosión fue
causada por el grisú
esta ya es la catástrofe minera de
Carbón más mortífera de Turquía desde
2014 cuando 300 un trabajadores murieron
en una explosión en la ciudad occidental
de soma